meet Sarah Sarah is a sales professional
and a tungl me user when she wants to
meet with clients she turns to tungle me
because with tungle me there are no
costly double bookings no time zone
mishaps and no more email ping pong
trying to find a time that works for
everyone here's how it
works John is Sarah's client Sarah
emails him the details of an upcoming
project he wants to book a call to
discuss
so he clicks the tungl me link in
Sarah's email signature he arrives at
her tungl me page to see the times when
she is free he clicks to schedule the
meeting adds details selects a few
available times and
sends Sarah receives the email
invitation she sees the times John has
proposed overlaid on her own
calendar she picks a time that works and
clicks book meeting the meeting is
automatically added to Sarah's calendar
and John receives an email confirmation
to add to his
calendar it's as simple as
that Sarah's tongle me page only
displays times that she wants shown as
available she has set her availability
for mornings and afternoons every Monday
to Thursday she has also sink Tangled me
with her calendar so that as new events
are added to her calendar tungl me will
automatically update her availability
and she won't be double booked
Sarah has also chosen to add a photo
contact info and a link to her personal
blog on her tungl me page she can share
the link to her page anywhere she
connects she adds it to her email
signature Skypes it to clients tweets it
to followers posts it on her LinkedIn
profile and even prints it on her
business cards by signing into her tungl
me account she can also use tungl me to
send customized meeting invitations to
one or many people she starts a new
meeting
invitation adds details and contacts
selects specific times to propose and
sends tungle handles replies prevents
double bookings and automatically
adjusts for invitees time zones without
having them sign up it's a quick and
easy way for Sarah to let her network
connect to her so are you ready to
tongle